will it's grace on line one
hey can i stay at your apartment again
tonight of course
as long as you want what are you doing
i'm looking for tissues
i'll have your assistant get them for
you she's late again oh
fire her already i'm not gonna fire
karen her social contacts keep my
business afloat
why does she even work i mean isn't she
worth like a gazillion dollars
she feels working keeps her down to
earth i know
i'm late my driver had another bronchial
incident
oh that was disgusting i had to raise
the partition
but that's no excuse i should be
punished i'm writing you a check
karen tell grace you should fire you
grace tell will to redirect his anger at
his mother where it belongs
[Music]
call me later hi all right honey there
you go
guilt be gone
karen i don't want to check i want
assistance i'm the boss i give you
checks
yes you do honey and i love them i do
you know i keep them all right here in
this box
so what else danny and i got into a
fight
oh honey call him in makeup why would i
do that it wasn't my fault well in the
long run it doesn't matter
i don't know that there's gonna be a
long run uh
grace you're you're what
40.
i'll be 31 next month so i round it up
honey danny is a good catch you've been
living together for a year close the
deal already
i'm serious grace pick up the pace i'm
serious karen pick up the phone
oh my god would you look at that now who
in the world would be sending
oh carnations they must be for you
oh yep they're from danny oh well isn't
he a sweetheart
uh oh my mel
surprised you're still walking
[Applause]
give me that
[Laughter]
oh he is so great i can't believe i ever
doubted he was the one
[Music]
well that was a little harsh
good uh yeah yes yes it is he's a bad
person very bad
grace i think it's time for a couple of
blue bippies
i don't want any pills they're not for
you honey they're for me
you know marriage is what
marriage is marriage is okay what the
hell that's all you need to
grace no she's gone
she's gone and i'm sitting here talking
to myself like a crazy person
oh my god listen to me i'm still doing
[Music]
it
you